the american west has seen unprecedented
wildfires this year in washington state
oregon and california which has seen the
most total acreage burn
the glass fire is burning kind of in the
the footprints of sonoma
and napa county so there's over 475
physical wineries in napa county
with 700 separate grape growers while
napa county only produces around four
percent
of all of california's wine grapes
they still account for 9 billion
of the of the more than 30 billion
dollars that california
brings in annually through its wine
making so this region is incredibly
important to the west coast and into the
wine industry
the scale of the damage in napa county
and sonoma county is hard to assess
because of the evacuated wine owners
while the devastation is is kind of hard
to
total right now we can bet that it's
probably worth
millions of dollars lost more than a
dozen
wineries in napa and sonoma county
have reported damages to their vineyards
or structures on their property
one of those wineries is the napa valley
landmark the castella d
amarosa castle and and while the castle
still stands
a a farmhouse adjacent to the castle was
actually damaged and that farmhouse was
holding
holding precious wine that that the
winemaker had been
had been making for for decades a
building that's about 11
000 square feet it burned to the ground
and in that building um we had a
warehouse
with about uh 120 000
bottles of wine it's all gone i
have to say it wasn't all of our wine
most of our wine is in
the castle which was untouched but still
thousands of gallons of wine the wine
value alone
was about five million dollars at retail
it's like a bad dream and i'm hoping i
wake up and this never happened
i i couldn't believe that the fire would
ever consume
a brick and stone building the wine
industry as a whole is going to be
greatly impacted by the american west
wildfires this year wineries in
in the american west in california in
2020 we're already
facing major losses just due to having
to close
tasting rooms and clothes wineries due
to covet 19 restrictions
because of the wildfires in napa county
and sonoma county a lot of the wineries
aren't going to be able to use 50 of
their grapes and some even more
and so that's only that's only tacking
on to the losses already felt by
by the pandemic in 2020. we're going to
see effects probably for
two or three years because the the 2020
vintage
probably wouldn't even be ready until
around 2023 so
that's when a lot of these wineries are
going to start seeing seeing big losses
is years from now